bonjour jean marc jancovici par jour
vous êtes connu comme économiste
spécialiste de la question de la
transition économique environnemental
vous êtes chef d'entreprise vous avez
fondé le cabinet carbone 4 inquiète les
entreprises à définir une stratégie de
décarbonisation vous est aussi président
de the chief project vous êtes membre du
haut conseil pour le climat alors ma
première question j'ai envie de vous
poser c'est est ce qu'il est encore
temps pour la france de tenir ses
objectifs climatiques
alors il est encore temps pour le monde
de tenir les objectifs de degré parce
qu'en général quand on parle de
climatique ces deux degrés un objectif
dont on a parlé récemment qu'on ne peut
déjà plus tenir 61.5 degrés il ya une
raison à cela c'est que le temps qu'il
faut attendre pour que le surplus de co2
concret dans l'atmosphère ces purs en
totalité est supérieure à dix mille ans
donc en fait le lien 25 degrés en 2100
ils sont déjà embarqué quelque part dans
les émissions qu'on a déjà effectué
jusqu'à fin 2018 voilà donc cela on a
signé pour la seule question est de
savoir si on les aura en 2100 en 2080
2060 2040 voilà vous avez dit récemment
quoi qu'on fasse ce sont les 20
prochaines années seront les mêmes alors
ça c'est prêt contre la science du
climat nous dit depuis longtemps que
l'inertie du changement climatique est
tel que en fait quel que soit le
scénario d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre l'évolution physique du climat sur
les 20 prochaines années a laissé les
déclas elle aura lieu de toute façon
mais on peut tenir les deux degrés ce
qui veut dire soit dit en passant que
quoi qu'on fasse sur la baisse des
émissions
il faut par ailleurs en parallèle engagé
le chantier de l'adaptation parce que de
toute façon le climat va continuer à
changer donc les records de température
estivaux et hivernaux les records de
sécheresse les records de précipitations
tout ça va continuer à tomber
on va continuer à avoir les ruines de
plus en plus spectaculaire a observé en
février le typhon le plus puissant
jamais observée dans l'hémisphère nord
en février
donc tout ça va continuer à augmenter
malheureusement faudra subir tout sa
végétation va continuer à être agressés
les rendements agricoles être soumis à
des pressions en croissance et c'est
super ça mais il faut agir parce qu'on
peut encore éviter que ça s'aggrave et
en parallèle un moins on agit et plus ça
s'aggrave rapidement alors on peut
physiquement vont tenir les deux degrés
ça veut dire en pratique que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
planétaires deviennent nuls ou quasi
nulle d'ici 2050 à 2080 alors 2050 c'est
le moment où mes enfants ou mon âge
voilà donc je suis certain vieux crabes
à leurs yeux enfin je peux encore
complètement mort de 1080 c'est le
moment où leurs grands parents ont leur
âge en faisant rouler elles ont l'âge de
leurs grands-parents paraît que tu
réponds donc on voit bien que les
générations futures dans cette histoire
en fait c'est les générations présence
est déjà né sur elles sont fondées
depuis longtemps et or comme l'économie
mondiale est basée sur le fait d'avoir
des machines qui travaillent à notre
place que les machines consomment de
l'énergie qui est essentiellement
fossiles et bien baisser les énergies
fossiles
bc pardon les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est à dire l'énergie fossile
jusqu'à ce que ça devienne quasi nulle
en 2080 s'est contracté à peu près à la
même vitesse le parc de machines en
fonctionnement dans le monde et donc
s'est contracté à peu près à la même
vitesse le pib mondial
donc la raison pour laquelle on ne fait
rien de sérieux depuis qu'on a commencé
à parler du changement climatique c'est
parce que en pratique baisser rapidement
les émissions c'est récessif il n'y a
pas de moyen de compenser l'énergie
fossile à la marge on peut compenser à
la marge quand on regarde
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
on est passé de quasiment rien à 80 %
d'énergies fossiles entre 1850 et 1970
et depuis les chocs pétroliers c'est à
dire depuis 1970 ce pourcentage
d'énergies fossiles dans le mix mondiale
et constant à 80% il a un petit peu
baissé avec l'essor du nucléaire dans
les pays de l' ocde
il est un peu remonté au moment où la
chine a entamé son décollage économique
parce que c'était essentiellement basée
sur le charbon
sarr baisse à un micro au poil
avec un microscope à cause des éoliennes
et des panneaux solaires mais c'est
encore moins que le nucléaire à l'époque
voilà donc c'est globalement stable aux
alentours de 80 % et en fait quand vous
regardez physiquement comment remplacer
ces énergies fossiles par des énergies
renouvelables vous rendez compte qu'on
n'y arrivera jamais parce que ça demande
des disponibilités en biomasse si on
veut de la biomasse ou en capitaux
investis
si on veut des éoliennes ou en montagne
avec de l'eau qui tombe dessus
si on veut des barrages ou etc enfin
quelle que soit l'énergie renouvelable
que vous regardez ça demanderait des
ressources physiques pour remplacer les
énergies fossiles qui sont hors de
portée de nos moyens actuels et futurs
de toute façon il ya une espèce de
barrières physiques faut quand même
rappeler que les énergies renouvelables
c'est le monde dont on sort dire qu'il
ya trois siècles le monde et des 100 % à
venir et si on n'est pas resté 100% aux
nerfs dans le cadre du développement
industriel c'est bien parce qu'il y
avait des avantages physiques aux
énergies fossiles
alors ya des contreparties c'est
maintenant de celle là dont il faut
s'occuper mais il ya eu déjà il ya des
avantages physiques évident donc c'est
pour ça qu'on ait eu recours
donc on est prévenu il va falloir
choisir entre plusieurs catastrophes et
en tout état de cause vivre dans la
rareté sans doute et l'adaptation aux
changements plus que de rêver à un
avenir radieux alors plus on attend en
malheureusement et moi on choisira c'est
à dire que par ailleurs les combustibles
fossiles sont épuisables
les combustibles fossiles il faut entre
50 et 300 millions d'années pour les
faire le charbon c'est des restes de vie
ancienne des fougères qui ont poussé à
l'ère du charbon le carbonifère mois 100
millions d'années et le pétrole c'est
des restes de plancton et de micro
algues qui ont poussé en fin ou qui ont
vécu dans l'océan plus exactement
n'importe quand entre eux il ya 50
millions d'années il ya 400 millions
d'années donc aux échelles de temps qui
nous intéresse quelques siècles on peut
considérer que ce stock de départ est
donné une fois pour toutes il ya une
quantité donnée sous la croûte terrestre
de pétrole de gaz de charbon et les
mathématiques à ce moment vous interdise
d'avoir un approvisionnement annuel qui
soit indéfiniment croissant voire même
indéfiniment constant pour avoir tous
les ans la même chose jusqu'à la nuit
des temps quand la ressource de départ
est donné une fois pour toutes les
mathématiques vous disent que ça
obligatoirement une tête qui ressemble
un peu à ça l'extraction au cours du
temps dont climat ou pas climat de toute
façon le monde connaîtra un épisode 2
croissance subi de son approvisionnement
fossiles de toute façon par épuisement
géologique la bonne nouvelle c'est que
dans la zone ocde ça a déjà commencé
depuis 2006 et c'est la raison de la
grande crise financière de 2009 enfin
c'est un déclencheur de la grande crise
financière de 2009
et c'est ça qui va nous ramener dans pas
longtemps malheureusement un nouveau
gros coup de tabac économique donc si on
attend suffisamment en fait on aura
double effet kiss cool c'est à dire
qu'on aura à la fois la décrue de
l'énergie fossile qui va nous priver de
moyens d'action face à un changement
climatique qui à cause de ce que je
viens de dire va de toute façon aller
croissant donc le pari gagnant dans
cette affaire il est que tant qu'on a
encore des moyens économiques
il faut qu'on l'affect d'urgence à
décarbonés l'économie et pas à
l'intelligence artificielle ou à
d'autres trucs comme ça qu'ils nous
feront une belle jambe sur une terre
dévastée mais un jean marc jancovici
merci pour votre éclairage et on aura
l'occasion de reparler dans une autre
interview pour voir comment la france
peut avoir une stratégie dans ce domaine
ainsi